let's go next to our caller from the
nine one three area code caller from
nine one three hello hi this is Jack
from northeastern Kansas and recently I
started researching about alright I was
curious about their motives and the
argument I wanted to know
sure and they presented an argument some
of them did that was surprisingly
compelling in that they would show
statistics where Britain polled Muslims
and similar refugees or immigrants from
third world nations and they found that
among Muslims half of them in Britain
wanted to ban homosexuality and 1/3 of
them wanted to in-state Sharia law and
they argue that because people from the
third world has such different cultures
we shouldn't take in as many immigrants
up we shouldn't we should start
assimilating them slowly so that they
become more Western person
yep yep how do you square this with
statistics from countries like Sweden
where immigrants are committing violent
uh do you swear that with the thought of
mass immigration basically so there's a
couple different things here let's see
if we can pick it apart a little bit the
question about Sharia law is one that
gets bandied about a lot you know what X
percentage of Muslims say they want to
live under Sharia law I am and I am
hostile to any religious law being the
civil or government law I don't care
whether it's ten commandments from the
Bible being part of civil law or Sharia
law the Quran the ID doesn't matter to
me right I'm against it so I'd like to
put that out first
that being said Sharia law means very
different things to different people so
if you are a rural Muslim living in
Afghanistan Sharia law means something
very different to you than if it's asked
to someone that lives in Riyadh Saudi
Arabia for example so this is not a
defense of any religious law I'm again
right I disagree with the Muslims who
want that I disagree with Christians who
want abortion to be illegal because the
Bible says so I disagree with all of it
but we do have to understand that sure
eat do you want Sharia law to be the law
of the land means drastically different
things to different Muslims that's
number one now let's take the second
piece because that's an interesting one
which is half of Muslims want to ban
homosexuality how many Christians want
to ban homosexuality right I don't know
what the percentage is but if you survey
just Christians in the United States and
then say how many of you want to ban
homosexuality or at least eliminate gay
marriage you you would have to adjust
the question for sort of the
circumstances in which we're living you
would have a not extremely low number so
I just questioned whether those there
are good and bad arguments to say here's
what immigration policy should be but
citing those two bits of data for me is
not hugely compelling okay thank you
yeah all right okay very good that's a
big all right I guess I must have made a
compelling case there okay that's all
the time we have for live calls if you
didn't get on I apologize we do have a
dozen or so people holding still and I'm
sorry we weren't able to get to everyone
but we will take calls again and I look
forward to hearing from you